what's happening reject nation so after
putting up that
godzilla versus kong reaction i'm gonna
do a real reaction here for
wonder woman 1984 apparently ccxp
released a
60-second trailer i've been waiting all
day anxiously checking my phone to see
if a suicide squad trailer is coming out
as we all know wonder woman 1984 moving
to hbo max this
christmas and select theaters as well
let's see if there's anything
grand to take from here
will be different
that's a beautiful score so so
so beautiful
[Music]
there's so much love in this trailer
loving hope and unity
[Music]
there's so much swinging on lightning in
this wonder woman 1984
streaming exclusively hbo max december
25th
sequences shot with imax film cameras
gonna really take advantage of watching
this
on my television with those imax cameras
i'm excited to watch it not gonna lie
i'm very excited i have
grown used to the fact that i will be
watching this on hbo max when it comes
out and that did look beautiful the
score was great i love all the themes
displayed here that's one thing that i
got from this was that i remember when i
was at a youtube event
and patty jenkins was speaking one thing
she really talked a lot about
was the mastery of tone how tone is one
of the most important things you gotta
really
know how to capture properly when making
a movie you know even though it's only
one minute long
there's something about the mood of this
particular trailer maybe it is the music
or you know the selection of shots with
unity love heroism that is on display in
this trailer that actually felt the most
akin out of the other two
longer trailers this felt the most akin
to actually the first wonder woman movie
for me especially on the heels of them
talking about releasing this on december
25th
of sharing the message this movie has to
offer to the world and then
you know we looked at a lot of those
first reactions yesterday and they were
discussing how this is a movie that
probably right now that we all need
and you do get that sense of there's
hardship
but there's a lot of hope and love out
there as well and we all need to stick
together there was that was like kind of
the impression that i was at least
gathering from this trailer backed with
some
bitching shots of her swinging on
lightning man how cool was that and i'm
curious to know uh let me know in the
comments are you part of the group that
will be watching this
in the theaters i do gotta say though i
do gotta
say this is like the gazillionth wonder
woman trailer and we still haven't
gotten a real godzilla versus kong
trailer i feel like that's what
most of us were waiting for they could
have stolen the show would see cxp
they could have been the hot they could
have been the talk you know but right
now they do have wonder woman coming out
in a couple weeks so i get the marketing
strategy of wanting to push
to make sure people are watching this on
hbo max or
the local theater is probably most
likely hbo max for most people you know
i'm just saying warner brothers
just saying it could have been a
juggernaut this weekend if you release
some godzilla versus kong footage either
way guys what you think of this trailer
subscribe
click that notification bell keep a look
out for our review considering doing a
movie commentary type of thing i've
never done that for the channel and like
hey let's watch a log and do a
commentary maybe we could do a live one
for wonder woman 1984. i wouldn't do
that on my first time watching this
first time i want to i watch it i want
to just
experience it you know like i have some
headphones on and be alone
try to replicate a movie theater
experience as much as possible as it
stands this is a really moving trailer
very touched
i'll see you guys soon